hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hector
excuse me i'm trying to do my
introduction here this is a horror game
that's actually pretty well made it's
made by a professional team of like five
people and it's supposedly very very
good because a lot of people were
requesting it while i was away at the
convention center doing a game show
award hosting thing that i was doing
that i already told you about
hello and if it disappoints me
well then that doesn't mean i'm gonna
kill the developers or anything that
just means i'm gonna be disappointed
okay i can't move is that supposed to
happen or did i mess up the controls
already
did i break the game i'm gonna go with
no
this place isn't what we thought it was
please help us
well i'll help you if you tell me what
the hell is going on because i'm more
than a little kid what is that
oh okay well then
thanks for not in the hospital starting
out no i spoke too soon
i'm an [ __ ] oh man i thought it was
gonna be
uh never mind never mind nevermind i was
under the assumption that i was gonna be
out in the woods like the trope of
horrors either you're out in the woods
or you're in a hospital so
i am assuming that i'm in the ladders
waterboard and oil are most
barbaric tools my favorite toy of all
is the noodle there is elegance about
sewing a man back together
that doesn't sound like a needle i know
needle noises
well my hand is not as steady as it once
was
is that because you're old and frail and
a loser
even though you probably just
disemboweled me and all my intestines
are spray
i was going oh that's that's just a bag
of iv
drip i'm assuming the blood you want to
keep me alive for a little bit
and when am i gonna get sewed back up
because i seem to be in several pieces
around the office
okay do i need to crawl out of here oh
hello
that magically slid towards me what the
hell is going on here
this is supposed to be a psychological
horror game and a psychological horror
game means that it takes its time
to build up the atmosphere in the game
that exists now being here screaming at
you probably doesn't mean anything
in that regard but i'm gonna try my best
enough control to crouch
do i need to hide yeah do i need to be
stealthy
might i possibly be a security guard
yeah don't forget to take your meds you
need them down here i'll be the judge of
that
okay lighter lighter ah let me just
fiddle with it for hey
press three to equip benzo pills
benzodiazepine
okay i'll just slap did i
did i take any did i take some benzo
do i need more benzo
i don't know entirely what to expect i
mean like a lot of
hey oh that's not a thing
i'm reminded a little bit of dungeon
nightmares over here and i don't know if
i'm supposed to be going towards the
crying or not
hi thank you light that illuminates my
path
i don't know if i need to conserve
lighter fuel
but oh god panic
i'm assuming that's the mechanic it's
supposed to be i keep thinking
shadows in the darkness are actual
things why is everything all wibbly
wobbly
secrets are meant to be kept america
depends on it oh you look like you have
so many secrets there
so am i supposed to take more pills or
what
also where am i going why am i here and
what am i doing all those good questions
should i follow that arrow i'm gonna say
no slam that down
f to consume bills okay that's a little
better i guess
not really thought that was gonna be a
little child
singing ain't no singing children gonna
be tolerated around here
hello well this seems to be terrible
let's keep moving forward nothing bad's
happened yet
like i said it's psychological horror
which means it's gonna take a while
before something actually happens or at
least that's my assumption
i don't go into these games knowing much
about it so i'm just under
the assumption that based on my prior
experience with horror games
but this is supposed to be like a
like a well like a well-made game
i'm not sure if it's quite on the level
of like outlast or what have you but
it's better than say the random indie
games that i play that are made on unity
or whatnot not the unity isn't a bad
engine but
now whatever i'll shut up i don't know
anything about making games all i know
is that i play them i scream and then
i'm done
then i go home okay
wait this is the same room i was just in
yeah it's the same room did i loop
around and i didn't even know it
run oh i can run i could have been
running this whole time
oh running running's probably a bad idea
hello loose tweets sink fleets good i
guess we're in the future
so all righty then
so america went to some sort of war oh
crap you're one of them randomly
generated a-holes
oh crap oh crap
wait no wait what did i just give
oh don't you do this to me don't you do
that to me oh hey
oh no i'm getting vanished flashbacks
all right i'll interact with this door
sure yeah that's that's cool
but it seems to be locked ah piss
ah piss you you pissy pisser
don't even think about doing this to me
i
don't much care for it okay all right so
what have you
left now
there's some way for me out of the
dragon
okay oh
oh scissors drippy drop no need to worry
about the drippy drop
i probably need to worry about that
that sounds exactly like something i
need to worry about
i see something move
okay do i need to hide get open you
sassy door
oh come on now oh sometimes these hand
mechanics
a lot allah amnesia
they don't eyes work out so good my
shoulders are too tense
someone's he's crying
i don't know if i'm supposed to check
all these for more benzo
i don't even know when i'm gonna need
more benzo
but that wasn't a door before was that a
door before
was that a door before okay this game is
officially taking with me
careful come on
oh god damn it how am i supposed to do
that correctly
ah gotcha gotcha got you good gotcha
good
got me good too okay so i found a what
what is that what is that a battery why
do i need a battery
hey all right guys
okay
was that a thing was that a thing i need
to worry about
okay i guess not
oh i sure would like a flashlight up in
here
even in five nights at freddy's and gave
me a flashlight on the second one at
least
i'm going slow i'm going very slow okay
it was absolutely nothing i could have
sworn i saw something
but then again maybe this game is just
digging with me like usual
oh
i hear crying growling growling
crying hey
i don't think i want to go in there this
is a funny feeling i don't want to go in
there
i wonder if it's heavy breathing then
i'm telling you i should probably move
along
can i open this no or is this just a
door being a dick
oh boy so what do i do about this
what is all this what's all this huh
uh maybe i need to put my battery in
here maybe i need to consume my battery
okay so i'm assuming i'm not having
everything that i need here
oh what's that oh nightmare land is that
way okay i'll just go the other way then
so i'm assuming i need something to do
for that
but i'm assuming that i don't have it
yet it's either a key card or a key or
some mechanism that's going to open that
door
so once i find that i'll be able to go
where i need to go and then do what i
need to do
but i got to go back here through
douchey land do she mess with me change
the level land
anybody in the shower huh anybody okay
all right then cool cool cool this is
great i love this
i didn't go this way
was that actually a thing or do i need
to worry about it more
open up
okay i got a new battery i got a new
battery
that's good i don't like this by the way
did i mention don't like this
okay i don't know why the roof decides
to cave in all the time
i should get maintenance down here to
check up on that someone call ripley
we need an engineer stat
okay all right cool
i don't want to run what do i need to
run or did you
say raw the god of the song i need to
run
oh what was that it's all eyeballs
oh it's so quiet why is it so quiet oh
boy
oh crap baloney ah i'm [ __ ] oh there
we go
i'm not [ __ ] on the uh give me that i
don't know what that is
why do i need a note i need to run
there's a thing
oh god what happened here i don't know i
went into a detective's office somehow
everything's so calm except for me of
course
what the hell i don't even know what the
hell is going on here
oh did this get does this get red
did you get a oh this was open the whole
time i just wasn't pushing on it
great i need to take some benzo i need
pills pills will solve my situation
stop the water start the fire you want
me to burn the whole building down i'm
right there with you baby
i'm so into that plan you don't even
understand
oh hey oh hey that was
open before this game is a decking with
me
was that open before am i just crazy ooh
what's this
okay so i need to check my note okay
jackson is putting in a petition to make
our condition better
to make
okay i'm sitting at my desk pretending
to work if you look like you're writing
and focused on what you're doing nobody
bothers you
i've been watching the guy two desk over
for me for a few days now
i don't know his name yet he looks
agitated and then the doctor calls him
in for a therapy session
i'm not sure what they do to him in
there but when he comes out he's
placidly calm
he has this gold watch that they let him
wear i'm not sure why they let him keep
it if they complicate all personal items
when you're transferred to hector
they even took my bear i know it's
stupid but it helped me sleep
all righty then whatever you say there
buckaroonie
okay so that's
bad oh hey tapes full
what does that mean for me eject full oh
hey all right then what
bye
am i supposed to find a tape and put
that in there so i can play it
there's a bunch of tapes over here full
full full what does this find
out okay i got it i was on that train
of questioning i just didn't get there
fast enough for you lady
i'll get it i'll get here
i don't even know who you is i'm not
gonna have another presentable liberty
situation where i got friends that i
don't know
stranger danger indeed
another thing i should be worried about
i'm very concerned
okay so that's definitely nothing
i'm just very worried because the
monster or what i thought was a monster
showed up so unannounced
all it said was run and i didn't listen
to it why didn't i listen
we are watching over you we always got
your back
thanks buddy i don't want to go in the
short room
i don't want to go in the shower
i want to go in the short room the short
room sounds so much fun
oh do you guys see what i see in that
chair over there oh
oh it's moving i don't know
oh oh god damn it it was just a gurney i
thought i saw a guy in a wheelchair what
kind of [ __ ] is this
kicking with me game don't be digging
with me yet i'm not to the dignity point
i got my benzo pills i'm gonna slam down
my pills
ain't nobody gonna dig with me oh this
one's open
okay i see is this a short room i've
heard so much about
i'm getting a little bit stressed
everybody don't pay attention to me i'm
just your tour guide
this hallway of nightmares
that is an interesting way to think
about my job
i'm a haunted house tour guide why do i
even need to be here
i'm in the front of the line so i get
all the jump scares so you don't have to
suffer through them
or something like that
communications is there gonna be
something in comms
you're a different voice than before i
don't i ain't gonna listen to you i
wanna listen to the other
oh good great and i'm sure that music is
good too
what the hell am i doing i don't know
where i'm going i don't know anything
i don't know anything at all got another
note
okay we're being filmed and everything
everything we do here ends up on a tape
somewhere
everything i started seeing the place
differently after i realized that
those who've been here for a while
always kept their heads down they were
always hurt when you tried to talk to
them
they didn't want to implicate themselves
in anything i've walked by the
surveillance rooms before
but we don't have clearance to enter
it's a good bet that's where they're
keeping the tapes
cool oh this is me
oh is this one me oh this is me oh i'm
reading this one now okay
i could be wrong but i'm pretty sure
he's been working for two days straight
he hasn't gotten up to use the washroom
i haven't seen him in the mess all of
the dorms he hasn't said a word in days
he just sits there working sometimes i
hear him moaning a little bit from his
desk
i don't think he knows he's doing it is
he dead
i'd be willing to bet that he's dead or
maybe he's one of those zombies
i've been here before i think i just see
the same things and i assume that i've
been here but
in reality i have not because obviously
i picked up that new note in that area
there
what was okay just wiring all right
i don't know what i'm looking for well i
know what i'm looking for i'm looking
for a goddamn tape
but what i don't know what i'm looking
for if i don't give her a god why am i
out
that didn't make any sense i apologize
can i
thank you anything in here oh okay
i like the way things flicker and make
me terrified right as i
enter them oh wait i did go here
this was a loop
who's whispering oh
this is the surveillance room that noah
was talking about
i got the tape what do i do with the
tape
what do i do now what do i do now
do i go back how do i go back i don't
know how to go about oh hey
is this uh is this hector's room
well thank you i must have done
something good everything's getting
bright
i guess i gotta go back this is where i
go back
i'm sure everything's gonna be exactly
the same
help me okay how
oh that's just how did i get back here
no way this is just not the thing
that's not it something right here
so wait a minute something ain't right
i don't know how i got to this point
here i is
why are these so bright why is
everything getting brighter
it's completely counterintuitive to what
i normally know about horror games
they don't get brighter they don't get
better
it just progressively gets worse i'm not
talking about the quality of the game
i'm talking about oh
what is that why is it do i need benzo
slam it down bro
i took both of them probably overdose is
not that big
okay what i can't go in here anymore
oh yes i can
okay i've not been here why have i not
been here
i walked by the comms room because i
just didn't know that i could go in here
don't where's the goddamn thing
stop the water start the fire stop the
water start the fire stop the water
start the fire stop the water fire in
the tire
i wait
not cobra oh crap
so
what does it mean what does it want what
do i do
what do i do
okay
okay oh okay oh oh
oh okay
oh okay i see how this is
this is the most dictorious game i've
ever played
found a collectible good for me i'm such
a winner in life and things
i've only got whispers in my ear and
head
damn it why are they locked
damn it i'm not gonna find any more
pills am i
i don't even know what the pills are for
damn it
okay definitely locked okay
oh i see over here no this is where i
was
damn it i don't know where to go i don't
know where that monster went
god i've only seen the two dots of the
eyes that are the monster i've not seen
anything else
okay so this is where i came this is
obviously locked up
it's locked up too so
i thought that fan was the silhouette of
a person
jesus okay it's hard i get turned around
so easily around here
okay so i must go up here i thought this
then again this might be different but
this might lead back to where i was
before
oh good bright blinding light great
i found the tape how do i
kill kill what kill who
surveillance okay
i'm just gonna close this door right
here yeah
just gonna close that okay put that in
the game
i did it all right standing by
what is that what is that it was a purse
what's going on here
what am i doing all right i see a person
there
what does that mean
okay and why is that the only screen
that scratched up
probably bad sign probably a bad sign
did i do good
dude i won do i get a prize
oh
okay righty-ho
then kane is looking over here
he always stares at me i'm writing this
note so i look busy
i don't want him to come over he hurts
me
keep writing keep writing the note not
that it matters anyway
i'm one of the only women in hector and
kane is a [ __ ]
animal he comes into my dorm almost
every night
and he touches me i pretend to be asleep
until he finishes
i pretend to be asleep until he leaves
and then i cry as quietly as possible
so he doesn't hear and come back he gets
angry when i'm awake
oh why
oh good a doodle of a rat or a mouse i
don't know
oh
why am i being suggested to this oh hey
i don't like this i don't like it i
don't like it
i like it look i don't like it
i think my shoulders have been
permanently around my ears this entire
day okay
so uh god damn it i've been here before
but i don't know if i need to go back
here
how do i open this goddamn thing how do
i open this goddamn thing
i don't know the answer is i don't know
where's this go
toilet's in a horror game they're bad
why do i hear whispering i don't like
this game
i've been recording for a while wait why
why why why
i don't know what this game wants from
me right now
it's just a big ass mystery and i don't
know what i'm doing
hi how long is this game
i have no idea
hello are you hector
safe or something i don't know i don't
know
i don't know why am i being quiet
okay all right i think this is new
territory
i don't think i've been here before
totally fine
i know okay you've said that
a bunch oh what's this generators
that sounds promising god damn it open
up
okay generators how do i get the
generators going oh did it glow right in
here
this looks all very technical are those
fish great
what am i doing i don't know what i'm
doing i don't know how long this game is
i'm assuming because it's a full-fledged
title it's actually going to be more
than one episode
so i guess i don't know maybe i can
can you pull that damn door thank you
why does the goddamn door
not pull please
thank you please okay all right
so i'm gonna end this episode here i'm
gonna pick this up in another one
because i have a feeling it's gonna take
a lot longer than that
so thank you everybody so much for
watching i hope you're enjoying this
game
it's terrifying it's legitimately
terrifying like this is
really good i don't have no idea what
i'm doing and sticking with me but
either way that's all i know so let me
know
what you think of this game in the
comments below thank you everybody so
much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
hi yes good yes good gonna go up here
good
go dick with me
angling things